Matt shneidman is the Raiders beat
writer for the Mercury News and he joins
us now all right Matt what kind of drama
should we expect on Thursday night with
your Raiders I think you can really
expect anything you know if there's
anything I've learned about covering it
the team Jon Gruden is associated with
it's that nothing should come as a
surprise and I know the talk of the last
day who is this surprise pick gonna be I
said yesterday you know they could pick
boobie miles and I wouldn't even be
surprised because users who never know
what the Raiders are gonna do you know
if they get a guy like Quintin Williams
I'd be surprised because we've seen the
fortunes of this Raiders franchise the
past 10-15 years and if they get the guy
that everyone is saying oh they'd be
lucky to get him I'd be surprised about
that you know could it be a quarterback
short could it be a wide receiver
absolutely so embrace him for anything
I think the Raiders are doing the same
and I think that's what everyone's doing
because more so than really any other
franchise they've kind of been the
beacon for for wild trades and
unpredictability the past 10-15 years
who's in charge
on draft night I still think it's Gruden
but I think it's more so may auxin
people think you know obviously Reggie
McKenzie the last general manager just
less than three years ago one NFL
executive of the year that dynamic from
the start we knew that was all Gruden
not just because of what they're paying
him but because he just the
personalities you could tell that Gruden
was in charge whether it be the Khalil
Mak trade the Amari Cooper trade you
could tell Gruden was calling the shots
I think they didn't hire mike Mayock
and as you know you know mike well they
didn't hire him to come in and really
manage the nuances of the salary cap or
make every personnel decision they hired
him because he's one of the most well
respected draft analysts in the business
in the last 15 years so this week in
this war room for this 2019 NFL Draft I
think Mike does have a lot more of a say
then people might think and and if you
have John grooms here that step number
one into I don't want to say restricting
his power restricting his say but I
think the more mike Mayock input you
have this week the better what about
sending his scouts home that
they're not gonna be involved on
Thursday night or this weekend in
Nashville yeah I think that was blown a
little bit out of proportion just
because you know it's not totally out of
the ordinary that they get Easter
weekend off and I think it was expected
that there would be a lot of overhaul or
turnover in the scouting Department
after the draft because of the new GM I
mean you need the scouts up until the
draft because they've done a whole
seasons work of worth a whole season's
worth of work on these college guys but
I think the one thing that maybe was a
little eyebrow raising was that they
wouldn't come back and that you know
whether it be signing undrafted free
agents or guys in the late round that
may I think written may need input on
these Scouts reportedly won't be there
to do that so it was a little surprising
than not coming back part and how
they're staying home for good but in
terms of sending them home and then on
the back end them eventually not coming
back I wasn't too surprised by that and
if there was anything I take away from
it it's that Mayock is overcompensating
for kind of his tendency and the
tendency this time of year for for leaks
to get out and there have been leaks in
the building as recent as last year and
even so you know a couple weeks ago so I
think it's May out just being overly
cautious in his first year as a GM and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that I don't think that should be cause
for concern if you're a Raiders fan what
are the fans if you took a poll their
perception of Derrick cars would that's
interesting I think it's probably about
seventy thirty in favor of Derrick car
and that's pretty much what Raiders
Twitter has been all the talk about I
think if you pull Jon Gruden and mike
Mayock it's a little higher
I think Raiders fans realize and the NFL
world realizes that Derrick card needs
more around him
I mean since he broke his leg in that
second last regular-season game of 2016
he has been nowhere near the same
quarterback but that is also because
last year he had Jordy Nelson as his
number one wide receiver for the
majority of the season after they traded
Amari Cooper he's had an offensive line
last year that allowed him to be sacked
51 time
2016 and 2017 combined he was sacked
three six times so I think this year
you've seen it with the additions of
Antonio Brown Tyrell Williams making
shrimp round the highest-paid offensive
lineman in history this year is really
about surrounding Derek Carr with those
pieces and seeing who the true Derek
cars because I really don't think he's
guaranteed coming to Vegas with the
Raiders next year I guess that being
said that's why I don't think they're
gonna draft a quarterback this year I
think they're going to get him one more
year but then after this year I think
anything goes if Tyler Murray Falls he's
there at four what are the Raiders do I
think they trade back you know III think
Tyler Murray will be there I think it'll
go Quinn and Williams Bosa Josh Allen
assuming the Jets stay put and I think
the phones at Raiders HQ are going to be
buzzing off the hook and Mayo has talked
excessively about not wanting to trade
back but wanting to add picks in the 30
to 60 range because he feels especially
in this draft that's where a real hotbed
of hidden talent can be so I think if
Tyler Murray is still on the board at
number four you're going to get teams
like Washington like Miami buzzing on
your phones wanting to trade up ahead of
the Giants if they think they're going
to pick Tyler Murray or even doing ask
and who knows maybe doing Haskins is the
number one quarterback everyone's going
to covet in this dress so I think if
Tyler Murray's still on the board at
number four the Raiders resist that
temptation as much as Jon Gruden loves
Tyler Murray does he's a quarterbacks
guy he's a good player we know how much
he loves him but I do think they trade
back to the middle of the first round
and add some picks in the later runs
it's always interesting have fun on
Thursday night Matt thank you for
joining us appreciate it Dan thanks for
having me Matt shneidman he's the
Raiders beat writer for the San Jose
Mercury News for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app